this we need a strategy to tackle a
pandemic
and that means putting lives first not
profits
after 48 hours of restrictions the
protests
have started for now they're small
but very angry i think this week i've
seen an absolute explosion in the amount
of
almost contempt for the tory government
you know you've got the north is not a
petri dish over there you've got
anti-tory
graffiti all over the city i think it's
not only highlighted this north south
divide but it's highlighted
how angry people in the north are that
they're not being taken seriously
they're not getting the support that
they need
northern church leaders fear this divide
they've warned of social
unrest as millions of people like those
here in sheffield
struggle under the toughest coronavirus
restrictions
there does seem to be a feeling that
we're almost second-class citizens
really
i mean i think they've done brilliance
of our conservatives but
you're furloughing people and
[Music]
i just don't know where it's going to
end there is always that north-south
divide but
i think really government needs to pull
the finger out a bit more and think
about
the impact that it has for some of the
smaller cities we're not as big as
london
so the impact for us around the pandemic
is a lot it's a lot greater really
for many it's about fairness and holding
the government to a promise made
after the election we are going to unite
and level
up unite and level up but after downing
street refused to meet the financial ask
of manchester's leaders going into tier
three
here the underdog has become the
champion
andy burnham the mayor of greater
manchester went to downing street and
asked for financial support and a policy
for tier three region so realistically
he was never going to secure
but instead of it feeling like a defeat
actually what it's done is give him a
national platform
and what he and the other regional metro
mayors do with that new platform will be
critical for the success
of the northern powerhouse our metro
mayors
are the right people to lead the
recovery and they have made a good job
of making deals or almost making deals
but
standing up for their communities in the
process and what they now need to do is
make sure that
they get the recovery packages that will
mean that not only do we put right the
damage that's been done in the last few
months
to our economies but actually at the
same time close the north-south divide
downing streets next moves are important
there is trust to regain in northern
cities
and political capital one in the last
election
that they can't afford to lose catherine
of autopsy sky news in manchester